good morning
i'm assistant sheriff john mcgrath i'm
here to brief you and give you
additional details as we know them today
about the officer-involved shooting that
occurred on monday october 4th 2021.
this is officer involved shooting number
seven for 2021 fatal number four
at the same time last year
we had 15 option involved shootings
eight of those were fatal
this event was initiated as a possible
domestic battery
in progress at 6 38 pm on october 4th
this officer involved shooting occurred
in the 4100 block
of silver dollar avenue
las vegas nevada
89102 which is the spring valley area
command
as you can see to the scene to my left
the involved officers are theron young
he is 35 years old and has been with
lvmpd since 2014.
in this incident officer young was armed
with a glock 17 nine millimeter handgun
equipped with a tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired 16
rounds
during this incident
officer young is assigned to the
investigative services division gang
vice bureau
the second officer is joel blasko he is
31 years old and has been with lvmpd
since 2014.
in this incident officer blasco was
armed with a glock 34
9 millimeter handgun
equipped with a tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired
three rounds during this incident
officer blasko was also assigned to the
investigative services division gang
vice bureau
the suspect in this case has been
identified as demetrius roberts
he is 21 years old black male adult
he is 6 1 and weighs 218 pounds
as you can see his picture is on the
screen
in this incident roberts was armed with
a semi-auto taurus
g2c
nine millimeter handgun
the investigation revealed he fired nine
rounds during this incident
robert's charges if he had survived
include attempted murder on a police
officer two counts
shooting into an occupied vehicle
and child endangerment
during the investigation of this
officer-involved shooting was determined
that roberts took cover in front of a
vehicle which was occupied by his mother
and his two-year-old son
as roberts ambushed our officers he shot
through the vehicle placing his
two-year-old son in danger
you can also see the impact of his
gunshots in the photo you see to my left
the details of the officer-involved
shooting
are
on monday october 4th 2021 officers were
from the lvmp's gang unit were
conducting surveillance on a vehicle
that was parked in the alley
behind the 4100 block of silver dollar
this vehicle had previously previously
fled from officers during an earlier
traffic stop
the officers conducted their
surveillance we're in an unmarked
vehicle and were dressed in plain
clothes
at approximately 6 38 pm
a woman and a man demetrius roberts the
suspect were seen walking towards the
vehicle that the officers were
surveilling
robertson the woman appeared to be
having an argument and roberts is seen
by the officers grabbing the woman by
the arms
the plainclothes officers announced this
information over the radio
and requested a mark patrol unit to
respond
officer darren young and officer joel
blasker were riding together in a marked
patrol vehicle
and arrived in the alley seconds after
the request was made by the plainclothes
officers
as officers young and blasphemer were
exiting their patrol vehicle
roberts took a position of cover behind
a vehicle and opened fire towards the
officers
officer young returned fire
as he ran to find cover
his handgun had a malfunction but he was
able to clear it
after shooting at the officers
roberts ran away towards pennwood arvol
excuse me pennwood avenue
both officers chased roberts as he ran
between two apartments
two apartment buildings
officer belasco was running directly
behind roberts and officer young took a
different route
to cut off roberts's path
once on pennwood avenue roberts took
cover behind another vehicle and fired
his gun at one of the officers
both officer young and blasco fired
their guns towards roberts
once again officer young had a
malfunction of his weapon
officer young cleared the malfunction
and fired his gun for a third time
towards roberts as he was running away
with the firearm in his hand
roberts was stuck struck by the gunfire
and fell to the ground and officers
immediately responded
and
provided first aid
medical personnel pronounced
roberts deceased at the scene
the woman involved in this incident was
also struck by gunfire
she was transported to umc trauma where
she was treated for injuries and later
released
an officer was treated and released by
medical personnel at the scene after
being struck by shrapnel
i will now show you the body worn camera
video of the officer-involved shooting
after it's done playing i will take the
time to slow down the video and explain
what's occurring
[Music]
control d61 shots fired off in the
advent 4156
[Music]
did you know that suspect
[Music]
get down man
[Music]
so as you can see that happened really
quickly and it's hard to to see
everything that happened so i'll try to
slow it down a little bit for you as
officers are arriving there's no audio
because it takes 30 seconds for our
audio to kick in on body worn cameras so
as immediately they start taking fire
the officer has the malfunction he
clears it
meanwhile the suspect's running around
the other side of this building
officer blasco was in for pursuit
officer young right here on his radio
then goes around the other side of this
building
to try to cut the suspect off
so there's the suspect at the front of
this van you could see him the both the
officer and the suspect were using that
van as cover unbeknownst to the officer
so he he fires one round has another
malfunction clears that from behind the
vehicle
and then the suspects on the other side
of the van crossing the street
this concludes the briefing
does anyone have any questions
yes uh might be a dumb question but the
white vehicle that you showed that has
the
impacts to it yes is that a police
vehicle or is that whose vehicle is that
that's uh the suspect's mother's vehicle
i believe but that's the vehicle she was
driving
and the angle is the suspect's in the
front of that car and the officers are
getting out of their patrol vehicle
behind okay and then i believe you said
that showed the impacts of the bullets
coming through the vehicle is it
do you have are those bullets that
officers fired or was he firing from
within the vehicle or do you understand
the particulars yeah so the suspect was
firing from the front of the vehicle
towards the officers through the vehicle
the mother turned out not to be a very
good witness because she was
covering the two-year-old child to make
sure that she wouldn't be hit by the
bullets
just so i understand that the
suspect was firing was outside the
vehicle and firing through the vehicle
that's correct
and
did you find the shell casings and all
that from his from his weapon there yes
all the the suspects uh shell casings
are at the front of the vehicle eight of
them and then one is on pennwood
avenue and are you aware of any
significant criminal history or violent
uh activity on behalf of this individual
previously
so we don't discuss the the criminal
history of the
suspect
so i'm not going to get into that right
now
um
but he is from nevada and
that's all i'll say
and what was his two-year-old
child doing there and why was the mom's
car involved uh if you don't mind
explaining a little bit more about why
you're in the area why there was a child
leading up to this altercation sure the
female involved was the
ex-girlfriend of the suspect and she
lived there and mom was bringing the
child over to that address and
everything occurred in the alley
and we know that domestic violence has
just been on a rise this past few years
for example domestic violence homicide
also climbing within metro um explain a
little bit and touch on how these
situations can become very volatile very
quickly
well as you can see the plain clothes
officers
saw a potential domestic violence
incident and they called for assistance
and before they could even get out of
their cars they were taking rounds so
that everyone's tensions are high in
those situations you never know what's
going to happen and it's just an example
of when officers go on a call it's
unexpected what will happen then and
this is a good example of that
um of course we're all concerned
we're doing everything we can to lower
the incidence of domestic violence
especially repeated calls at the same
address and trying to get
assistance to those victims
thank you i appreciate everyone coming